today is the 200th birthday of the
famous German chemist Robert Bunsen or
Bunsen as he's called in English and he
of course is really famous for the
Bunsen burner and we've used it on quite
a lot of our videos never really looked
at it so come and see what a Bunsen
burner is it's a metal plate with a
small nozzle with a tiny hole and the
gas comes out along this pipe and up
through the hole and on top you put this
metal tube you can see it's just a metal
tube which has a slot in the bottom you
put another piece of tube with a
matching hole and you can rotate it so
you can open and close this little
window and this gets screwed onto the
top so if we turn on the gas and light
the Bunsen it begins with this rather
nice orange flame the orange color comes
from unburnt carbon it's very hot these
tiny bits of carbon rather like you get
in a candle flame and so the combustion
of the gas the burning of the gas is not
really very efficient and some of the
carbon is being wasted the natural gas
that comes out of here is largely
methane ch4 and so some of it is not
burning properly it's bright yellow
because the tiny particles of carbon are
so hot that they're glowing bright
orange
the exciting thing happens when you turn
the piece of metal and open the little
window below and this bouncing burner
was invented by Benson and his lab
assistant though most people have
forgotten the name of the labs assistant
now I can't remember either as I turn
this we mix the air much more
efficiently with the methane and so it
burns really well scientists were really
excited about the
havior of this and one of the things
that Benson is famous for is looking at
the light that was emitted from flames
in fact he used this burner to discover
the elements rubidium and cesium but
from the light that they emitted the
rubidium and cesium were in small
amounts in mineral water from some
German spa he discovered them using his
burner one of the things people use this
hot flame for is for blowing glass my
handshake too much for being a very good
glass blower but the idea is that you
rotate a piece of glass in the hottest
possible part of the flame which is the
tip of this blue cone and you can see
the orange color of the sodium being
evaporated of the glass and the glass
goes all soggy you can see here and when
it's really hot and soft and beginning
to glow quite red you can then pull the
glass out into a fine capillary tube
this was the first sort of burner the
first type of burner where you could
really control the size of the flame and
you could make it in different sizes
they have the top of the Bunsen burner
was sometimes made like a fishtail so
you got a flat flame that was quite
large and so it was the ability to
manipulate fire and to heat things
precisely that made it so important when
I was a student or at school
I think the bouncing burner was much
more an icon of chemistry than the
periodic table my first book textbook on
inorganic chemistry that I used as a
teenager never mentioned the periodic
table but it had pictures of Bunsen
burners and we used them all the time so
when when I first started teaching
chemistry teaching the chemistry lab I
was teaching their lab over there on the
other side of the building
and a really stupid student and I'm
sorry to say he was stupid managed to
put the rabbit tube from his bouncing
burner under the flame and the tube
caught fire and burnt through and
suddenly there was a flame coming out of
the tube like a flame thrower all over
the bench and it was at that moment that
I realized that I didn't know where the
fire extinguisher was and it took me
nearly a minute to find find the fire
extinguisher but by which time the whole
bench was burning and we put out the
fire but for the next few years every
time I went into that lamp I saw a black
stain on the bench to show how stupid I
was that I was running a lab without
knowing where the fire extinguisher was
Bunsen was a really talented chemist who
made contributions over large areas of
chemistry he discovered the elements he
laid the foundations for spectroscopy I
think probably he would be a little bit
disappointed that he's being remembered
on his birthday for the bouncing burner
because I'm sure he didn't think it was
the most important part of his career
Bunsen with very famous as a very good
glass blower and apparently he could
last blow until his fingers were smoking
and had gone black the nerves in his
fingertips had gone I've burnt myself
quite often glass blowing I never had my
fingers going black or smoking
and anyway smoking isn't allowed in the
lab anymore